Spider-Man: Far From Home follows a literal
class trip, but it's also a head trip, and
that goes for the characters in the movie
as well as its events.
Some characters play bigger roles than expected,
some aren't who they appear to be, and still
others are a total surprise.
Here are some characters from Spider-Man:
Far From Home with more meaning than you realized.
Be warned: Spoilers are undoubtedly coming.
As she does in Homecoming, Betty Brant first
appears in the Midtown High School news show,
and later she goes on the trip with the rest
of the class.
Her role is largely comic relief, with her
sudden, hyper-close dating relationship with
Ned undercutting some tension.
It's also her curiosity that leads Ned to
invent "Night Monkey," the great character
find of 2019.
What you might not know is that Betty has
as long a history in comics as just about
any Spider-Man supporting character, first
appearing in Amazing Spider-Man #4 in 1963.
She and Peter met as employees of the tabloid
newspaper the Daily Bugle, where she was Publisher
J. Jonah Jameson's secretary, a role the character
also filled in the Sam Raimi-directed Spider-Man
films.
Comics Betty even dated, then married Ned
Leeds, though the comics version of Ned doesn't
share too many similarities with the movie
incarnation.
Comics Ned died, and now Betty is an investigative
reporter herself.
Though Robert Downey Jr. doesn't have any
scenes in Far From Home, - well any new scenes,
he’s in the BARF flashback - Iron Man hovers
over everything like the Mark V armor.
Obviously, there's his relationship with Peter,
which leads to Peter being entrusted with
"EDITH," the augmented reality system powered
by Tony Stark's glasses, whose initials stand
for "Even Dead, I'm the Hero."
There's also his connection to Mysterio.
The big reveal that Mysterio is a fraud and
criminal is no surprise to comics fans, but
the detail that Quentin Beck once worked for
Stark Industries, creating the hologramatic
"therapy" tool we saw Tony use in Captain
America: Civil War, is totally new.
"Plus, 611 million dollars
for my little therapeutic experiment?
No one in their right mind would have ever
funded it."
It immediately ties Mysterio into the MCU
in a compelling way, and gives him something
in common with The Vulture from Spider-Man:
Homecoming: hatred of Tony Stark.
It's ironic that Tony yelled at Peter for
making messes in Homecoming, but Peter's had
to clean up Tony's messes twice now.
And Iron Man does technically appear at one
point, rising out of Tony's grave in one of
Mysterio's illusions.
Based on the character design, it's a moment
that's a clear nod to fans of the Marvel Zombies
comic series.
We've never seen Peter's Uncle Ben in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe.
He's barely even been mentioned.
Ben's violent death at the hands of a nameless
crook, thus teaching Peter the tough lesson
that…
"With great power comes great responsibility."
...is a story that's already been told twice
on film, in 2002's Spider-Man and again in
2012's The Amazing Spider-Man.
Plus, Tony Stark has filled the role of Peter's
father figure in the MCU.
But Ben's presence is felt in Peter's innate
humility and his deep-down need to help the
little guy.
Peter carries his uncle's lessons with him.
He also carries his suitcase.
As Peter is packing up to head off to Venice,
there's a quick shot of a set of initials
Peter's luggage: "BFP" for "Benjamin Franklin
Parker."
It's the most overt reference to Uncle Ben
in an MCU movie yet.
Not only does blustery newsman and Daily Bugle
Publisher J. Jonah Jameson appear in Far From
Home's mid-credits scene after Spider-Man
gets framed for Mysterio's crimes, he's also
played by the actor who played him in the
Sam Raimi Spider-Man trilogy, J.K. Simmons.
"Spider-Man wasn't attacking the city.
He was trying to save it.
That's slander."
"It is not!
I resent that!
Slander is spoken.
In print, it's libel."
He looks a little different than he did in
the Raimi movies; Simmons' naturally bald
head has replaced the comics-accurate flat
top he sported in the earlier films.
But he's perfectly Jonah in every other way,
stoking public sentiment against Spider-Man
and painting the superhero as a threat.
Or maybe a menace.
Jameson's appearance and the news report that
accompanies it sets a whole new status quo
for MCU Spider-Man going forward, in which
he'll surely be regarded with a lot more contempt
from the public.
Can the Anti-Spider Squad be far behind?
Once Mysterio's plan involving the holograms
and drones is revealed, the audience is left
to wonder when the Nick Fury and Maria Hill
they've been seeing have been the real ones,
and when they've been fakes generated by Mysterio's
tech.
Certainly it's worth parsing the movie to
see when the two former S.H.I.E.L.D. operatives
are holograms and when they're not, but even
the "real" Fury and Hill aren't who they seem
to be.
In the post-credits scene, it's revealed that
they've been Talos and Soren, the husband-and-wife
Skrull leaders from Captain Marvel, the entire
time.
Fury has asked them to take his and Hill's
place for a bit while they relax on a virtual
vacation.
That is, until Mysterio causes all that chaos
and Talos has to call Fury to come back.
Knowing that recontextualizes every scene
with Fury and Hill, and invites a second viewing.
Also, Soren's a pretty great shot with a sniper
rifle, huh?
Though Mysterio builds them up as hyper-powerful
mythological beings, the Elementals are little
more than a trick of the light.
They're realistic projections emanating from
the holographic technology Quentin Beck created
as a Stark Industries employee, and the damage
they do comes from the drones built by fellow
ex-employee William.
But, as Mysterio observes, people believe
they're real in a post-snap world, because
they'll believe anything.
They're really close to being believable for
the comics fans in the movie audience, too,
because three of them closely resemble the
Spider-Man villains Sandman, Hydro-Man and
Molten Man.
At one point, Flash Thompson even reads a
Wikipedia entry for Morris Bench, the comics
alter-ego of Hydro-Man, reciting a creation
story that pretty closely resembles Hydro-Man's
comics origin.
It clearly seems like a fake-out directed
at all the Hydro-maniacs watching.
Brad Davis, who didn't get snapped and therefore
had five extra years to grow up and get handsome,
serves the role of Peter's romantic rival.
Peter's so desperate to beat him out for MJ's
affections that he accidentally almost kills
him with a drone.
There was a version of Brad who appeared in
exactly one comic issue: 1979's Amazing Spider-Man
#188.
Mary Jane Watson goes on a couple dates with
him while on a break from dating Peter.
He's an Empire State University football star
and kind of a jerk, but he doesn't take any
pictures of anyone with their pants down like
the movie version does.
Also worth noting is Jason Ionello, who appears
once again as Betty Brant's co-anchor on the
Midtown High news show, was a recurring character
in the comic series Untold Tales of Spider-Man.
He ran with Flash Thompson and a group of
other popular teens, often picking on poor,
nerdy Peter Parker.
Dimitri appears to be Quentin Beck's right-hand
man through much of the first half of the
movie, staying mostly silent while ferrying
Peter back to his Venice hotel and driving
the bus that takes the Midtown High students
to Prague.
We never quite figure out what his deal is
in Far From Home.
After the big reveal that Mysterio has a whole
team of former, embittered Stark Industries
employees working with him, Dimitri sort of
just disappears from the movie.
Pre-release rumors pegged the character as
Dimitri Smerdyakov, also known as The Chameleon,
one of Spider-Man's oldest villains.
Maybe he still could be.
Someone had to hand that doctored video over
to the Daily Bugle, after all.
And, like the Skrulls, the Chameleon can change
his appearance to look like anyone.
He could be hiding in plain sight.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Spider-Man
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.